to some it seems president biden is
talking tougher to the vaccine hesitant
americans in his own country than he is
to the taliban in afghanistan that's
just one of the many aspects of this
crisis we're going to address tonight
with the author of the new book the long
slide and the host of tucker carlson
originals by the way a brand new episode
debuting tomorrow on fox nation called
the ufo files tucker carlson good to see
you sir
oh shannon breen my favorite thank you
for having me listen i want to start out
by first of all talking about the
situation what the president said
tonight about how we could have
calculated what's happened in
afghanistan here's what he said on abc
so you don't think this could have been
handled this actually could have been
handled
better in any way no mistakes
no i i don't think it could have been
handled in a way that there
we're going to go back in hindsight and
look but the idea that somehow
there's a way to have gotten out without
chaos ensuing i don't know how that
happens
i don't know how that happened so for
you that was always priced into the
decision yes
okay so tucker to me that sounds like
the president admitting that he thought
us leaving was going to be chaotic the
situation of getting people out
americans whoever else were going to
help what does that sound like to you
you know clearly they knew that this was
going to happen they did it anyway the
question is why i you know i can't
answer that but
the and let me just say as forthrightly
as i can i'm glad that we withdrew from
afghanistan um 20 years is enough we
didn't get anything out of it it was
time to go
but to give priority to afghan citizens
over american citizens which is what
they did and are doing now
is stunning to me it's such a clear
display of their priorities which are
also on display in our southern border
that they're putting foreign nationals
ahead of american citizens this is the
u.s government it has only one
responsibility and that's to u.s
citizens period if we help others along
the way good for us that that's a
virtuous thing to do but its moral
obligation is only to american citizens
and to leave them behind and sort of
cavalierly say well you know they can
get to the airport and we told them they
had to leave really that's not how you
treat people you love that's how you
treat people you despise and have
contempt for i think it's shocking well
yeah and we we had the notice from the
state department that a number of people
shared with us today that went out to
americans there saying you got to get
yourself to the airport and then we can
help you but also in bold all-cap
letters said we cannot guarantee your
safe passage to the airport so
to the average american i think we want
to have confidence that our state
department our military our white house
has got horrible situations like this
under control i want to play something
from the defense secretary austin today
when he was asked about getting people
to the airport and how we do that
it sounds like you're saying this
depends on diplomacy with the taliban
that's it that's our only option is
getting them to agree to do this
well let me
add something here elaine um we got a
couple
so what you heard there was dead silence
from the defense secretary kind of
looking around and then and then general
milly picks it up but
is that where we're left now that we're
negotiating with the taliban to get
americans out i mean luckily the
president has said no more arbitrary
august 31st we'll keep the military
there longer if we have to because
americans are still there
but you know do we doubt that the
taliban will break an agreement with us
if it comes down to us getting americans
out of there what's the priority
first it's so distressing to see a
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
and the secretary of defense who are so
clearly out of their depth i mean this
is not the interior department okay it's
not the department of energy these are
very serious jobs this will not be the
last foreign entanglement in the first
biden term okay there's a lot of serious
stuff on the horizon and have having
those people at the helm were more
worried about white male rage than they
are about the taliban is is very
distressing i think for any american no
matter who you voted for second this is
the us government now we may be in
decline as a world power you know we
could debate that we definitely have the
power to get american citizens out of
afghanistan safely it's that's just
foregone we can do that if we wanted to
we chose not to
and i i think it's unforgivable i do and
i say this is someone who supports the
withdrawal from afghanistan i'm not a
neocon in any sense but you have a moral
obligation to your own citizens period
it's not complicated at all and if you
you know if they're slow in getting to
the airport send a helicopter and go get
them they're americans you're the
american government
you you know you work for them what is
this yeah i think this is one of those
moments that will define this presidency
i think for the history books and for
americans today sitting at home watching
this on tv
um so let's hope that they stick to
those pledges that they're going to get
every american out we all have
connections and stories and people that
are there on the ground thank god
a friend of mine her niece and husband
an infant baby sat at the tarmac sat at
that airport luckily they were able to
get there before the taliban you know
built this ring around it but even then
it took you know a couple of days for
them to get out luckily they're at a
safe third country now
but in the meantime i want to talk about
your book uh it is a hit you are the
minus touch on writing books people love
what hearing what you had to say unlike
what my dad used to say there are some
people with the minus touch that
everything they touch turns to mufflers
you're not one of those people uh tell
us about the book
and what it's about
that's my real estate investing career
um
the book is a collection of journalism
over the past 30 years pieces that i
wrote i was a magazine writer for a long
time
before i went into television then after
i continued to write magazine stories
and report them from various places
because i liked it it's interesting you
learn a lot you the the beauty of
magazine journalism is the opposite of
what i do now you have to listen in my
current job i'm just on transmission
hear me talk more talking but in
journalism you actually have to shut up
and listen to other people talk which is
very good for your soul and it's also
the only way you learn anything so i
loved it
in the process of writing this putting
this together simon schuster my
publisher canceled a book by josh hawley
because they didn't like his politics
that struck me as a grave offense i felt
implicated in it because they were
paying me money to do my book i was part
of the problem so i wrote about that i
found it detestable it was done by a guy
called john carp who runs the company
who's a democratic partisan effectively
an operative a censor
and i was just deeply offended by what
he did and i said i'm going to write
about this and they were afraid to
cancel my book about them cancelling
other people's books so they published
it
but i felt it was a story worth telling
because what they did was wrong and it's
it's happening all across american
society but book publishers can't be
censors period that's a perversion it's
it's wrong well from the dedication on
uh it is vintage cheeky tucker carlson
who speaks truth uh in ways that people
sometimes do or don't like to hear it we
love to hear it we're glad to have you
and it's called the long slide best
wishes with the book and always great to
see you thanks tucker
i really appreciate it thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else